on vous remercie d'être avec mon direct
sur rt france alors vous êtes donc
favorable à la vaccination des enfants
on sait que le vaccin ne protège pas de
la contamination mais protège des formes
graves quelle est donc la proportion des
enfants justement qui font cette forme
grave alors d'abord le vaccin protège
aussi de la comtesse où il réduit la
transmission entre les individus
donc c'est important la vaccination des
enfants va permettre ainsi de casser la
circulation du virus au sein de cette
tranche d'âge de 5 à 11 ans parmi
laquelle le taux d'incidence aujourd'hui
est très élevé d'autre part il protège
également des formes sévères et en
particulier chez des enfants puisqu'on
sait que même si les enfants ou font
moins souvent des formes graves que les
adultes il en fut tout de même à l'heure
à laquelle on se parle il ya une
quarantaine d'enfants qui seront
hospitalisés en réanimation pour une
forme sévère de lakovic 19 donc oui
malheureusement les enfants peuvent
aussi faire des formes sévères et se
retrouvé hospitalisé alors on sait un
certains parents se posent la question
de l'intérêt de faire vacciner leurs
enfants la faute selon vos propos de
certains experts qui continue de
minimiser l'impact du coc vie 19 chez
les enfants oui il faut me ce n'a pas de
sens de minimiser l'impact de lakovic 19
chez enfants à double titre le premier
d'abord parce que la circulation du
virus dans cette tranche d'âge 5 ans 11
ans aujourd'hui est l'un des principaux
moteurs de la propagation du barrio
mikron est donc ou tribus très fortement
au nombre élevé de contamination
quotidienne
ensuite et je le dis à nouveau parce que
c'est important de le répéter un
malheureusement nos enfants ne sont pas
épargnés par les formes sévères et donc
il faut là encore les protéger ce
d'autant que beaucoup d'entre eux se
retrouve contaminé donc même si la
proportion d'enfants faisant une forme
sévère est faible eh bien voyez s'il ya
de très nombreux enfants qui sont
contaminés le nombre d'entre eux qui se
retrouveront à l'hôpital
continuer d'augmenter dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines de façon
inédite
alors on le sert la vaccination des
enfants est facultatif pour le moment et
elle se fait avec l'accord parental
justement comment on obtient l'adhésion
des parents
je pense que la première le premier
argument à l'encontre des parents c'est
d'insister sur le fait que la
vaccination a d'abord pour objet de
protéger l'enfant lui-même ensuite de
protéger l'ensemble de la famille au
même titre que la vaccination des plus
âgés protège l'ensemble de la famille
celle des enfants également donc je
pense que
l'argumentaire vis-à-vis des parents et
celui ci le vaccin est très efficace
chez les enfants le vaccin est très bien
toléré chez des enfants et donc nos
enfants n'encourt pas de risques
particuliers liés à la vaccination en
tout cas pas plus que les adultes que
nous sommes alors la présence arbres
vous demandent également une meilleure
prise en charge de la gestion sanitaire
dans les établissements scolaires en
quoi cela consiste précisément
dès lors que les écoles parce que les
écoles primaires aujourd'hui sont
caractérisées par un taux d'incidence
très élevée du virus et du variant
mikron dans les prochains jours agir à
ce niveau est un élément extrêmement
fondamental pour lutter contre la
pandémie y agir comme en maille agir
principalement en retardant la rentrée
des classes le 3 janvier qui risquent de
catalyser
l'épidémie et la vague omicron donc ça
c'est la première mesure la deuxième
mesure importante est celle encore une
fois de de l'intensification de la
vaccination est finalement de cordemais
la reprise de la rentrée scolaire avec
la vaccination des plus jeunes et faire
en sorte que l'on aille à l'école une
fois vacciner et pâle inverse là on
parle de la potentielle saturation des
hôpitaux c'est justement pour ça que le
gouvernement appelle à la vaccination
qu'en est-il les services hospitaliers
pédiatriques
par les services hospitaliers
pédiatriques comme les services d'uld
sont sous extrême tension à la fois par
l'aco vide mais aussi par les très
nombreuses autres urgences que que nous
accueillons simultanément donc oui les
services pédiatriques de mes collègues
pédiatriques sont aussi saturé que les
nôtres les services des adultes donc
nous sommes sous tension de la même
façon les personnels et la réserve de
moyens humains de ressources humaines
est très faible et donc notre capacité à
répondre à un afflux plus important de
patients il en particulier temps fort
malade risque d'être très compliqué au
mois de janvier
dj anna merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en rappel vous êtes chefs de
service réanimation à l'hôpital raymond
poincaré à paris et signataires de cette
tribune à du jdd merci à vous